if you stand for something important
want to make a positive impact on the
world and make money in the process I'm
going to share with you a powerful clip
from Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz that I
think you'll enjoy hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe in entrepreneurs
and recently a buddy of mine friend of
the channel Jason fonseka put me onto
this clip from Howard Schultz who's a
CEO of Starbucks the clip is from a
shareholders meeting at starbucks where
one of the shareholders as Howard
Schultz about his decision to support
gay marriage the shareholder was
concerned that starbucks valuation would
start to decrease and they would lose
business because not many people
supported gay marriage Howard Chilton's
response was just awesome and if you
staying for something in your business
you're going to enjoy it let's roll the
clip it is not the lens in which we r
that decision is through the lens of our
people we have we employ over 200,000
people on this company and you want to
embrace diversity
disgusted that you can get a higher
return than the thirty-eight percent you
got last year is a free country you can
sell my shares in starbucks and by sure